une belle robe 1 et puissant un style
des saveurs fruitées lamoussa tient en
verrines et pas uniquement les
spécialistes aujourd'hui elle s'apprécie
avec la même rigueur que le vin bière
qui roule n'amasse pas mousse
[Musique]
ce soir ces dégustations ludique aux
berrichons
au programme des blanches des brunes des
américaines des allemandes des
classiques aux bouteilles les plus
inédites
le dégustateur sont là pour apprendre et
surtout pour apprécier
[Musique]
la légende voudrait qu'un jour des
chasseurs cueilleurs et laisser une
jarre en terre cuite rempli de céréales
à l'air libre en dehors avec les
intempéries
l'eau est rentrée dans la jarre puis une
fermentation naturelle c'est fait ils
sont revenus nous retrouver il y avait
des petites bulles ils ont goûté ils ont
ressenti l'ivresse alors là il faut
imaginer une dr à 0,5 un degré d'alcool
plutôt une soupe de céréales tiédasse
que une bière telle qu'on la connaît
actuellement sous l'oeil et les papilles
averti de francis les idéologues la
dégustation se poursuit en monologue de
la bière il présente schémas graphiques
et petite anecdote au public de
néophytes
c'est en faisant un peu de chimie et un
brin d'histoire que nos dégustateurs
appréhende la mousse c'est assez
surprenant
la diversité des bières qu'ils peuvent
et qui peut y avoir quoi inciter des
bières les goûts les couleurs
[Musique]
que te ne vit un petit peu novice on
n'imagine pas la diversité c'est une
dégustation c'est con qu'on dit tu vas
où on aime on a quand même nous on a
quand même - quoi on retrouve des
similitudes je dirais dans l'est dans
les parfums dans les arômes dans les
choses comme ça là on n'a pas encore
goûté d'être exotique mais il ya des
vins ont peu goûté on peut percevoir des
arômes de fruits exotiques des arômes
florales des choses comme ça donc
quelque part on trouve un peu là c'est
très marquée c'est un peu plus facile si
le parallèle avec le vin est récurrent
c'est que sur ces terres
traditionnellement viticole le pli est
difficile à prendre
parfois il faut juste se laisser porter
il n'y a pas de bonne guerre ou de
mauvaise bière c'est juste une question
d'essayer de goûtez moi je considère
qu'il ya une bière pour chaque personne
pour chaque palais pour chaque moment de
l'année pour chaque moment de la journée
également on peut trouver ce qu'il faut
c'est y avoir accès dans cette cave à
bières installé à bourges depuis deux
ans la mousse s'exprime sous toutes ses
faveurs
le berrichon un pari de passionnés un
lieu où brasseurs amateurs et confirmés
se rencontre aussi pour échanger
quand les gens poussent la porte c'est
vraiment pour découvrir des choses alors
effectivement on va partir sur les
basiques au début parce qu'on a un peu
peur et après effectivement avec les
conseils on arrive toujours à trouver
des choses qui vont être entre
guillemets complémentaires pour pouvoir
les emmener sur d'autres bières sur des
bières qu'ils connaissent pas du moins
des saveurs différentes
il ya une multitude de palettes qui a
cliqué possible
une palette de couleurs et de saveurs
qui s'obtient toujours grâce à la même
combinaison de l'eau du malt du houblon
et des levures quatre éléments à la base
de tout bière l'ingrédient le plus
essentiel c'est le malt
il donne couleur et goût à la bière il
s'obtient par la trempe la germination
et la torréfaction des céréales la
plupart du temps l'orge parfois le blé
le seigle ou l'épeautre ou alors on a vu
la partie trompe prend pas là c'est la
germination c'est des germoirs quand les
gras commence à germer c'est là où il ya
l'apport d'enzymes alpha millas bêta
mais la doctrine aux limites bétail mais
kannad les enzymes qui vont travailler
dans le brassage brasseur industriels et
artisanaux viennent s'approvisionner ici
aux malteries franco-suisse d'issoudun
l'entreprise transforme et céréales
depuis 1894
avec l'émergence des microbrasseries il
a fallu adapter les commandes
si la production des brasseurs
artisanaux et modeste moins de mille
hectolitres par an elle est plus
exigeante sur la qualité des matières
premières le circuit court pour un micro
brasseurs pour berrichon c'est très très
important ils veulent pas ils veulent de
l'ordre la région
malte est transformée dans la région et
ne pas faire plusieurs kilomètres pour
arriver chez eux et ça c'est très très
important pour les microbrasseurs la
partie en va des régionales locale et
artisanale
une fois les matières premières en stock
le brassage peut commencer
mais avant tout il faut qu'on casse et
les grains broyer le malt avant de
débuter l'empaquetage période de chauffe
de l'eau et du malt nécessaires pour
transformer la mine donc en sucre après
rinçage et filtration des drèches il
faut reprendre l'ébullition du liquide
filtrer et c'est à ce moment que l'on
ajoute le houblon
une fois le mourre refroidi le brasseur
complète la recette avec les levures la
fermentation des buts et par là même la
production d'alcool
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est en limite de champagne
berrichonne et et précis a la
particularité d'être traversés par une
sorte de d'une sableuse récit est
construit sur du sable
et ce champ là à la même nature de sol
et donc c'est un sol sableux profond et
qui serait propice justement à installer
une au blosne hier francis notre it
locked rend régulièrement des nouvelles
du projet d'adrien membres de
l'association houblon de france il
milite pour la culture de nouvelles
variétés de la plante et la
réintroduction de houblonnière dans tout
l'hexagone
véritable nerf de la bière le houblon
est aussi une denrée très prisée
il ya une énorme demande des brasseurs
et notamment brasseurs artisanaux
microbrasserie pour ses hauts blancs
différent beaucoup plus aromatiques qui
leur permettent d'avoir une palette
organoleptiques une palette d'arômes
beaucoup plus marquée avec des bières
traditionnelles grâce à ce petit
ingrédient en évitant de faire un ajout
adjonction d'aromates donc on peut
véritablement parler d' or vert en berry
ici même après six minutes ronces pape
pourrait être dans les années à venir la
première houblonnière en berry entre le
python et les coteaux
depuis 15 ans la plus ancienne des
brasseries artisanales du berry prospère
installé dans les anciens abattoirs de
sancerre la doyenne des brasseries fait
dans le rétro cuves en cuivre et
étiquettes comme à la belle époque celle
où la bière coulait à flots non monsieur
retrouvé que ce bâtiment à sancerre dans
le milieu viticole et puis le
puis quand un chavignol apporté et je me
suis dit faut que je monte une brasserie
qui ressemble à une brasserie donc c'est
vrai qu'au lieu d'acheter des tanks à
lait de bricoler j'ai acheté une machine
qui ressemble à une vraie brasserie etc
est en cuivre on s'est un peu aussi pour
ça pour respecter l'appellation aussi
pour pour avoir une image de marque pour
moi c'est bien mais pour l'ensemble la
brasserie la cense airways a misé sur
une installation automatisée et une
fabrication de bière à l'allemande
un choix innovant à l'époque pour
anticiper aussi les critiques des
industriels face à l'émergence des
petits brasseurs les grands groupes
pousse de plus en plus pour un
encadrement strict de la fabrication une
idée qui ne passe pas chez les artisans
quand je suis arrivé ici on m'a dit on
ne mettra pas le monde france air sur
une bobine donc c'est bien ça les limes
à l'image l'image qu'ils étaient
représentées c'était de la bibine
maintenant je ne veux pas dire que la
bière et au niveau du vin mais on a
autant de travail à savoir faire et c
c'est tout cet apport de d'éducation de
la clientèle afin de la clientèle louis
qui a amené à redorer le blason de la
bière et dont les industriels profitent
aujourd'hui maintenant alors c'est vrai
que c'est eux qui ont fait tourner
brasseurs de france qui se continue mais
on a été les représentants et sénat
c'est nous qu'ils ont à voir n'est la
belle image que la bière commence à
avoir aujourd'hui dans l'indre les
doyens ce sont les baies l'on installé
en 2004 au pied des malteries d'issoudun
il tient un bar brasserie pendant huit
ans avant de déménager à villedieu sur
indre
aujourd'hui ils militent pour leur
indépendance ont fait pas le même métier
nous on fait de la bonne bière ces
génies du marketing seront vos défendent
c'est une liberté de création
mais ils veulent bloquer liberté
d'appelation ce qu'on veut défendre
aussi c'est s'est fait complice installé
avec moment qu'on a prouvé nos capacités
c'est pour défendre les intérêts des
petits brasseurs face aux industriels
que naît le syndicat des brasseurs
indépendants en avril dernier
fédérations nationales pour concéder
aussi les nouveaux arrivants et le
belgique n'est pas en reste
la loi sur arnon la trinquette et la
benjamine des brasseries berrichonne
eloi a fait le choix du bio comme
beaucoup des nouveaux installés et les
contraintes restent pourtant les mêmes
ce qui va toucher la bière en fait tu
dois être très propre quand on va mettre
les lumières ça sera
juste eryl très sucré donc qu'il sera
prêt pas bon pour le développement de
toutes les bactéries des nouveaux locaux
déjà trop étroit pour l'ambition de
notre jeune brasseur
bientôt il faudra construire un bâtiment
pour stocker la production à peine
installé déjà un oeil sur l'avenir avec
sa compagne agricultrice ils ont décidé
de combiner leurs activités au terme on
voudrait
voudrait cultiver les céréales pour la
brasserie on a commencé à planter du
houblon tout ça donc on voudrait c'est
d'avoir une démarche globale sur le
lierse on essaye de
d'être le plus maître de ce que l'on
fait de savoir le mieux possible ce
qu'on transforme
après on pourra probablement pas tout
avoir en local mais on va essayer de
maximiser si on arrive à produire lors
ge de base et le transforme et nous
mêmes il n'aura déjà 80% du 80 % de la
matière première qui sera d'ici un
projet de ferme brasserie pour proposer
un produit 100% local une belle idée de
plus en plus prisé par les jeunes
brasseurs devenir professionnel sans
avoir jamais brasse et c'est quand même
un gros pari parce qu'on sait enfin
c'est comme si on voulait faire
pâtissier sans avoir jamais cette gâteau
vraiment c'est vraiment la brasserie
c'est vraiment la cuisine c'est vraiment
mais vraiment très très proches et c'est
chez lui que matthieu brasse encore
aujourd'hui entre de cuisson du loup une
séance de dégustation des précédents
brassens un peu plus un peu rousse belle
couleur cuivre ont comme ça peut-être
carbonatation avant d'avoir une
expérience de brasseurs faut avoir une
expérience de deux heures d'aidé à toute
proportion gardée ou pas ça dépend d'où
l'on vient et après je pense qu'il faut
aimer la cuisine tout simplement
c'est vraiment du c'est la cuisine donc
on a des on a des ingrédients qu'on peut
pas trop sur lesquels on peut pas trop
influent et après c'est juste un mix on
dit voilà je met un petit peu c'est un
petit peu c'est un petit peu de ça et
c'est comme quand on fait une recette de
cuisine c'est exactement pareil
en plus d'être une passion la bière est
devenue son métier
aujourd'hui ces chèques thomas mousseau
de la brasserie où je n'ai non qu'il
fait ses armes
installé depuis huit ans en berry ce
brasseur microbiologiste de formation à
partager son expérience dans un livre un
guide à l'usagé du brasseur amateur et
commençait aussi en étant brasseur
amateur ce qui donne
quand même des bases pour écrire un
livre là-dessus puisque embrasseurs
embrasse père matters on touche à plein
de façons de faire différentes donc on
va tester des centaines de recettes de
berre et ça je pense que ça donne quand
même une une idée de ce que c'est que
brassage amateurs qui est différent du
brassage propres des recettes et des
astuces
recueilli par une journaliste berruyères
un ouvrage médine berry avec l'idée de
rendre accessible à tous cette pratique
handycam des gaulois les gaulois aime la
bière hymne la cervoise si on l'appelle
plus comme ça il ya une mode et en même
temps je pense que ça va durer parce que
le fait maison on est tous le contexte
écologique et on se rend bien compte que
le fait de faire les choses à la maison
coûte beaucoup moins cher
et puis aussi c'est de convivialité on
est entre potes on a décidé d'acheter un
peu de matériel et on va se mettre dans
son garage et on va fabriquer notre
bière on peut arriver en soirée avec un
bouquet de fleurs mais c'est quand même
plus place je trouve d'arrivée avec sa
bière maison
plusieurs sites internet proposent déjà
des kits pour réaliser sa bière maison
la cervoise a donc de beaux jours devant
elle
si les français boivent moins d'alcool
il cherche la qualité auprès des
brasseurs artisanaux en berry
l'engouement pour le breuvage ne fait
que commencer
voilà moi elle a toujours appris à
permet de tout se réunir autour d'une
passion qu'elle adhère au china tout le
monde a déjà vu une guerre dans sa vie
comme du vin et tout le monde a envie
d'apprendre tout le monde a une marge de
progression considérable
c'est l'intérêt juste de faire de la
bière c'est de la bouteille
[Musique]